it's important today for labret
scoreless as the first combined ripped
results and is real encouraging the
thumbs enroute health I think the main
thing is that we made promises to the
shareholders and the city when we
announced the merger and you're seeing
by obviously this energy upgrades and
the underlying performance it would the
wallet on that so that's that's
encouraging and what about the trading
environment I mean last year was
interesting lots of football results
went your way the horse racing was a
complete nightmare yeah well we know the
fuel cheltenham last year which would
then this year so with a good shelter a
couple of weeks ago football obviously
with less that had a big impact so and
that's represented than the results but
overall our digital revenues up group in
the retail revenues up so what
encouraged and current trading is
looking strong as well so there's a lot
to be positive they had to sell three
hundred odd betting shops to get in the
merger past the competition authorities
are you going to be closing more stores
anyway as a result of declining trade no
I think I think the plan is probably
maybe 20 or 30 or 40 this year just as
normal business as usual most about his
license expiring and but we're hoping to
the stay at the current position that we
are but we're obviously with the scale
that why Brooks coral have we are we are
better positioned than Moore's to deal
with any rate we're headwinds that may
come our way who are mentoring reg Lee
regulatory headwinds you've obviously
got the government review going on right
now of stake sizes on on the machines in
the betting shops what's your
expectation as to how much you're gonna
have to reduce stake sizes by well I
mean I've cut this this conversation off
in the past quite quite a few times the
the the trainer was a call for evidence
and based on the evidence independent
evidence has been provided by KPMG
there's no relationship between stakes
and prizes and obviously problem
gambling behavior and I think that is
really important the better way to deal
with problem gambling behavior there's
more interventions and chops more
personal interventions and I think
that's an area that we need to look at
and I think what's important from our
perspective we have three stakeholders
we've got our shareholders and obviously
my job is to protect shareholder value
we've got our colleagues which I have
19000 I am not prepared to chair trade
college jobs for steaks when there's no
impact in problem behavior and we've
also got customers and one thing that
people don't realize that as labret
score on the sect that have the largest
number of staff intervene and problem
behavior because it's not publicly
funded and it would be better for people
to gamble in a responsible environment
rather than elsewhere but you're really
saying there's no connection between
stake sizes when you can gamble 100
pounds per spin every 20 seconds on
these machines well the reality is in
these things as well I mean average
state size is just over 4 pounds you
know the average time on the machines is
10 minutes and we just want to put the
record straight and I think I've said
before I mean that that is the facts and
that is the evidence that is there now I
am NOT seeing here that some of our
customers demonstrate problem behaviors
but it is better to have them in the
short with 19,000 trained staff at
Ladbrokes coral looking for those
patterns and intervening we are
appropriate I think that is a far more
responsible bit today and using many
political bets right now ahead of
article 50 being triggered well it will
start to come up with article 50 coming
up I think I think if you look at where
we expect to be we usually see that just
before the the I've of the results are
known so 30 to 1 faretta laser next
country 2 leaves quite an interesting
bet 8 to 1 that will still be in the
European Union by 2020 is a good value
bear as well we never comment on the
political aspects of it but were happy
to in a bit and take that bet from me